hi guys dr. Berg here in this video
we're going to talk about vascular
calcification now this is the number one
cause of death and chronic kidney
disease it's also the best predictor of
heart attacks way better than high
cholesterol or anything with LDL so
calcification what happens is the valves
the arteries the aorta is becoming
calcified is becoming stiffed there's no
more elasticity and that leads to you
know heart heart attacks and the other
thing that it'll do is it raises blood
pressure so that's kind of a precursor
and if you're getting blood pressure
from calcification of the arteries your
blood pressure will stay high it doesn't
come down like some types of blood
pressure come up and down this one just
stays high because the arteries are
becoming calcified your arteries are
basically becoming bone so there's a key
vitamin vitamin k2 responsible for
inhibiting calcification and making sure
that the arteries state arteries and the
bone stays bone so it drives calcium
from the vascular into the bone itself
so it's good for off to ProSource
osteopenia and it's a kind of a
calcification inhibitor so vitamin k2 is
always deficient in dialysis patients
you know end-stage renal failure
vascular calcification they're always
going to be low in vitamin k2 it's a
relatively new thing for people people
haven't heard about it but it's probably
going to be very popular in about 2 or 3
or 5 years from now because it's amazing
actually it's a it basically can reverse
hardening of the arteries so you want to
do your own research on that now the
other thing that works with vitamin k2
is d3 a vitamin d3 is also always
deficient in chronic kidney disease as
well as vascular calcification and
probably the reasons why bloating kidney
is because d3 the active form of d3 has
to be converted through the kidney and
so if that doesn't happen you're not
going to absorb it so therefore you're
gonna have a lot of calcium issues
okay what do you get k2 well you can get
it from sauerkraut you can get it from
other fermented vegetables there's also
a fermented soy in Japan called nado you
can get that even as a supplement it's
also in all the grass-fed dairy butter
cheese it's in grass-fed meat it's in
grass like pasture-raised eggs egg yolk
so it's in actually the fatty foods the
very foods that doctors have been
telling people to avoid because of heart
problems which is interesting but
vitamin k2 is an amazing decalcification
vitamin and if you're on warfarin or a
cumin cumin which is basically a blood
thinner unfortunately that blocks this
whole process so you're going to be
deficient in k2 so here you are
preventing a clot but that you end up
getting calcification so it's really a
situation so hopefully the doctor can
give you other options but that is a
situation so I just wanted to summarize
if you go to the doctor and you're
checking your cholesterol levels always
have them check for calcification in
your arteries and the carotid and see if
it's a situation and if it is start
loading up with k2 I'll put some links
down below to get some more data Thanks
what's the next part what am I going to
say take 5 do it and where am I going
with this
hey if you're enjoying my videos press
the subscribe button below and I will
keep you updated on the future events
thank you so much